georges samueli chercheur au global
policy institute c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soit bonsoir georges
samueli merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france savoir pourquoi cette
coopération militaire avec la pologne la
pologne est un ami fiable pour donald
trump demain 30 ans n'a pas beaucoup en
europe en ce moment notamment
l'allemagne n'est pas vraiment une
grande amie donc ils aiment l'idée de
glorifier la pologne qui correspond qui
remplit ses obligations par exemple en
matière de portions du bébé consacrées
aux dépenses militaires contrairement à
l'allemagne
contrairement à l'allemagne la pologne
achète du gaz naturel liquéfié aux états
unis alors que l'allemagne achète son
gaz naturel à la russie a grâce au
gazoduc nord stream 2 et bien sûr cela
irrite fortement donald trump
il ya également peut-être un peu de
sympathie politique envers le
gouvernement conservateur du président
tout da alors ce déplacement de troupes
vers la pologne
est ce qu'on peut y voir un message pour
la russie effectivement la russie n'en
n'est pas très contente
on pourrait dire que cela viole l'acte
fondateur des relations entre l'otan et
la russie qui interdit tout au
déploiement majeur de troupes sur le
continent européen
mais un redéploiement des forces
pratique vraiment lieu vers la pologne
on peut se poser la question
il est difficile de dire si les 9500
nous avons vraiment être bien retiré
d'allemagne ils menacent de le faire
mais donald trump ne l'a pas encore fait
et la pologne devraient payer beaucoup
d'argent sans doute plusieurs milliards
de dollars 2 milliards de dollars pour
accueillir ses troupes et la question
c'est est-ce que ils ont cet argent au
vu de la crise de la pandémie et la
pologne n'a pas grand chose en matière
d'infrastructures qui permettrait
d'accueillir les troupes américaines
contrairement à l'allemagne
donc on ne sait pas vraiment si cela va
arriver et on ne sait pas ce qu'elle
nombre de militaires seront déployés
vers la pologne
alors quelle peut être la réaction de
moscou la russie est très mécontente
vis-à-vis de beaucoup et de nombreux et
cision de l'otan par exemple les
manoeuvres à proximité de la frontière
russe et l'expansion constante de l'otan
qui a acceptent de plus en plus de
membres et sans oublier bien sûr le rôle
de l'otan lors du conflit de crime et
notamment concernant le traité à fenioux
le traité s'il ouvert donc la russie n
est pas très contente de tout cela la
ligne à ne pas franchir seraient les
armes nucléaires les armes nucléaires
sont explicitement interdite par l'acte
fondateur entre l'otan et la russie il
ne peut pas y avoir de déploiement
d'armes nucléaires dans cette région et
certains hommes politiques pensent à
supprimer les armes nucléaires sur le
sol allemand en tout cas ce serait la
ligne rouge pour la russie alors on
rappelle quand même en retirant ses
troupes d'allemagne 2
le trump voulait en quelque sorte punir
entre guillemets les allemands pour leur
budget de défense insuffisant mais aussi
peut-être pour le gazoduc nord stream 2
on peut dire cela oui je le pense
le gazoduc north stream ii a fortement
irrité donald trump
car donald trump a pour fond de commerce
la vente des produits américains et ce
gaz naturel liquéfié est un produit
phare
donc il est vraiment énervé parce que
l'allemagne se tourner vers la russie
bien que bien sûr c'est bien moins cher
pour l'allemagne que le gnl américain il
n'a pas de très bonnes relations avec la
chancelière allemande angela merkel tout
récemment madame merkel a dit qu'elle ne
participerait pas au sommet organisé aux
états unis et donald trump a des idées
tranche l'europe en général ils
imaginent que les états unis paix pour
la défense de l'union européenne et que
l'europe n'a aucune reconnaissance pour
lui l'otan a sa place dans un musée
c'est une relique historique et bien pas
du tout un tas - du il a raison il a des
idées très très archaïque sur la
relation entre les etats-unis et
l'europe
merci à georges ça me lis d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur arte france pour
vu de l'extérieur ce soir